la scolarisation des enfants handicapés
un parcours du combattant parfois
impossible déjà dénoncé en 1961 c'est le
mois où les enfants retournent en classe
une par foyer pleure pour le patient
mais dans beaucoup de maisons derrière
des fenêtres restent des enfants qui
rêvent d'aller à l'école
ces enfants sont enfermés dans une
prison celle de la maladie dans cette
archive la journaliste s'indigne du sort
réservé aux enfants handicapés mais
aussi de l'impuissance des parents ont
la leur visage est ce différent deux
choses d'abord là
faire un instituteur privée ou une
institutrice privé mais c'est à peu près
impossible et c'est là que c'est trop
faire on s'est trop cher évidemment
du coup c'est souvent le système d avec
le concours des parents d'élèves l'école
de quartier où les municipalités exemple
en 1964 bien sûr les locaux sont
vétustes et exiguës bien sûr un
appareillage plus complet et des
aménagements hydro terapeak par exemple
serait souhaitable mais cette école même
modeste est une des rares du sud-est à
la valeur d'exemple 1975 première prise
de conscience au niveau national avec
une loi d'orientation qui préconise
l'obligation d'éducation des enfants
handicapés
un texte symbolique jamais suivies
d'effets il faudra attendre les années
80 pour voir la mise en place de classes
spécialisées au sein même des écoles
dites ordinaires que les enfants soit
intégrée c'est une bonne chose puisque
pour un enfant se retrouver avec les
autres dans son milieu de vie sociale
normale dans son milieu scolaire dans un
milieu scolaire normal puisque c'est la
vie de l'enfant parties le milieu
scolaire
ça permettra plus tard s'il continue sur
cette lancée de s'intégrer dans le monde
du travail
depuis 2005 et la loi pour l'égalité des
chances
le nombre d'enfants handicapés
scolarisés en primaire ou au collège
ordinaire a augmenté passant de 133 1838
pour la rentrée scolaire 2004 à 341 1500
pour la rentrée 2010 8
mais ces chiffres ne doivent pas
enjoliver la situation tous les enfants
ne sont pas encore accepté à l'école et
certains parents doivent trouver des
solutions à l'étranger ou faire pression
sur le corps enseignant comme cette
maman
en 2012 elles occupent jour et nuit une
salle du collège avec d'autres parents
d'élèves venus la soutenir
c'est l'injustice et l'inégalité on
estime que tous les élèves ont par la
même chance de réussir leur scolarité
le gouvernement actuel prône une école
inclusive et promet même que 50% des
enfants pris en charge dans des
instituts médico éducatifs seront
accueillis à l'école ordinaire d'ici
2020 les associations s'en réjouissent
mais alerte sur les moyens à débloquer
pour mettre ces mesures en oeuvre
[Musique]